[Music]
hates juice hates
[Applause]
[Music]
juice
want to get
AIDS I'm not a boob
guy oh
yeah oh
I'm a
female I didn't mean to offend
you oh
[Music]
yeah here we
go apolog wow what a hole
[Music]
a
that you are going to publish this in
any event and I am telling you that if
you do that you do it at your power
website designed for the explicit
purpose of sexually exploiting children
there are fewer evils greater than the
abuse and exploitation of innocent
children there's a very strong
likelihood that we get sued for putting
the story out but we're not going to
stop and I am advising you in the
strongest possible terms not to publish
such a
thing let me have your attention for a
moment cuz you're talking about
what talking about bitching about
YouTube strikes some son of a in
Silicon Valley screwing with the
algorithm someone screwing with your
notification system let's
talk about something important they are
here all but one I'm going anyway let's
talk about something important put the
coffee
down coffee is for mud clubbers
only oh you think I'm with you
I'm not with
you I'm here from
downtown I'm here from Rumble and I'm
here on a Mission of
Mercy
your name to man Tim yeah and you call
yourself a Mud Club salesman you son of
a I don't got to listen to this
crap you certainly don't pal because the
good news is you're fired the bad news
is you've got one night one
night to regain your jobs at mug Club
starting with tonight with tonight's
show
oh have a got your attention now good
because we're adding a little something
to this month's sales contest as you all
know first
prize is a fully loaded Ford
Raptor anyone want to see second
prize pair of Ranger
panties third prize is you're
fired you starting to get the
picture are you laughing now
you've got subscribers leads potential
mug clubbers get their names and get
them to join mug Club the new pitch all
you can watch unlimited nine bucks a
month you can't sell that you can't sell
you are hit the bricks pal cuz
you're going out the notification system
is weak the notification system is weak
you're weak I've been been in this
business for 15 years what's your name f
you that's my name you drove here in a
Jeep Patriot and I in a slightly more
expensive crossover SUV that's my name
and your name is you're
wanting you can't sign someone up for n
bucks a month go home and tell your wife
your troubles there's only one thing
that counts in this life and that is to
get people to sign up for the club that
is mug you hear me you
a
b m a always BB M mug clubbing always be
mug clubbing always be mug
clubbing a i d a attention interest
decision action attention YouTube's not
notifying you of lot with Crowder videos
do I have your attention interest are
you interested I know you are you even
hit to download the rumble app you close
or you hit the bricks decision have you
made your decision for mug club and
action a i d a get out
there
out there just waiting for you to fight
for them to give you their support are
you going to take
it are you mad enough to take it
incredible what's the problem sailor you
four-eyed Fu you're such a hero you're
such a rich guy what are you coming down
here with a bunch of bums like us for
huh you see that
mug you see that mug yeah that mug is
hand etched this year I signed Nick
doollo Brian Kalen Mr guns and& gears
Hodge twins and Alex Jones who' you
recruit see pal that's who I am and
you're
nothing nice guy I don't give a
football skills you go home and
watch Rudy with your pants down you want
to work here close you think this is
abuse you think this is abuse you
sucker you can't handle this how in the
hell can you handle what you'll get out
there in YouTube comment section you
don't like it leave I can go out there
tonight tonight the materials you got
and get 15,000 new mug clubbers tonight
in two hours can
you can
you go and do
likewise a i d a yes YouTube hates you
yes meta hates you Black Rock hates you
for sake the doj hates you and
that's a good place to start
because people are still out there
sating up on Rumble for your free
content looking for you to fight for
them and join Mud
Club get mad you sons of bites get
mad because you know what it takes to
sell Mud
Club it takes hand edged
hand painted
balls to grow M
Club go and do likewise
Jens Muk club's for
closers join Muk club today for $89
annually to support content like this
and get access to the entire
network louderwithcrowder.com mugclub
[Music]
[Applause]
that's what I
[Music]
know
glad to be with you that sounded like a
fast fade that sounded like a fast fade
it was a fast sip which you know I went
to Barber Shop they wanted to give me a
fade make me look like house party glad
to be back M I'm glad to be back with
you uh it's a new era it's a new era
here at uh at mug Club Rumble lot with
CR some big announcements and you know
hit the like button share all of that
because we did the Clean Slate campaign
little bit less uh little little bit
fewer clips and promo and social media
algorithms we will be relying on you you
either either want to be here or you
don't because we make it worth your
while we aim to serve you and uh
tomorrow major hidden camera mug Club
undercover uh release where we will be
tied down with legal
fees maybe but we'll do it anyway so uh
what are we talking about today let me
just give you the rundown the UFC is
pretty damn based the only Sports
organization that we know of of course
Taylor Swift is still dating that guy
but she's she's not in the UFC do we
have the uh okay uh we have Ronda santis
D santis dropped out time to close Ron
santis bar stool is going to rumble
exclusively yeah the Border invasion is
continuing where I have to admonish
myself because I gave you some wrong
information last year and uh also on mug
club we have a uh Jewish sperm owner was
denied but that'll be mug mug Club
exclusive because there's no way there's
no way we could do
that here way it's not possible so my
question is how has your life improved
since the hashtag clean slate I know a
lot of you did this I I actually was
confused because I looked at a bunch of
friends who were followers I'm like
there's nothing on their Pro oh Clean
Slate right it's like when the power
goes out and you forget you're like I
guess I'll just I need to go why is the
light switch oh the power's
out you surprised yourself I'm just
going to go uh microwave some popcorn no
you're not son of a that's what always
happens so if at any point at any point
today while you're watching you see
this that means leave YouTube had on
over to rumble anyway because we would
love to see uh no one at YouTube and
everyone on Rumble all right moving on
number two in command uh CEO Captain
Morgan how are you sir doing well how
are you good yeah I'm always nervous
before yeah always nervous when you come
back and by the way these breaks aren't
breaks like we have man we four hours in
I think investigations coming out uh and
new content new shows we had it's just
you just can't do it all at once and boy
the legal fees only because they said
they were going to sue us is what we're
saying yes they sent us a letter like
the day we it was weird I don't know how
I don't we can't tease too much because
then when you see it tomorrow like oh
well that makes sense you're going to
die wait hold on me or you all of us
dang it this is going to be Skynet with
you rattling the fence very soon yeah
it's going to be Maui 2.0 yes basically
and when you hear this that means that
you know who's in third chair it's not
who
but who
plural they them they them
it's the Hodge twins at conservative
Twins and of course you get their
Thursday show their full show
exclusively on mug Club Keith Kevin
Hodge how are you s doing good man life
is good life is good it's been a while
since we've been here yeah thanks for
helping us back thanks for thanks for
the
enthusiasm you right away you're going
to have some white people like that's
the thing once you Legalize It they
think they can do it all the
time wake and bake no one says wake up
and drink but all of a sudden when it's
the ganja too
yeah well you guys have a new studio
you're building right now right yeah
yeah so their show their Show's been off
for just a little bit they're building
the new studio should be back really
soon here we'll announce it as soon as
it's ready to go I hear you guys have a
pretty good guest oh yeah well so that
be lot pretty good why don't I know
anything I don't
know good guess so smash the like button
I guess if you're on YouTube let's move
on here yeah there you go well that's
the rumble button but on yeah I hit the
YouTube One Screw YouTube
okay so the UFC you know Sports is is is
uh um it's usually a silly thing it's
usually a bad place it's funny to me
when you see NASCAR you see the NFL and
they're uh really trying to appeal to
the woke uh contingency of this country
they couldn't be more out of touch and
this is the thing it's not these when
you see these and there's a disconnect
this is something we've talked about
quite a bit uh it's not the fans who
dictate what happens with the sport it's
the executives right these people from
the top down are looking to incorporate
Dei initiatives these people from the
top down are looking to try and appease
uh International markets you saw that
with the NBA and LeBron so sometimes
it's easy to say man they're going to
cannibalize themselves well well they're
not because they don't really care about
you and that's why we're so grateful to
have mug Club where we are actually
beholden exclusively to viewers like you
one exception the UFC this may not be
your sport I get it but the president
Dana White who used to kind of tow the
line has decided he's going to let his
freak flag fly and he defended his
Fighters uh and their ability to speak
freely and here's the thing he def ended
them at a press conference this Saturday
in Toronto Ontario Canada which is a
horrible place where dreams go to die
you obviously give a Long Leash to your
Fighters about you know what they can
say when they are up there with a UFC
microphone and you are getting into
territory of homophobia transphobia like
is there I don't give anybody a leash
well I'm saying you a leash I'm like
spee that reporter would like it control
what people say
going to tell people what to believe
going to tell people I don't can tell
any other human being what to say what
to think and there's no leashes on any
of
them what is your
question I was asking that question I'll
move on though yeah probably a good idea
that's ridiculous to say I give somebody
a leash Free Speech Brother people can
say whatever they want they can believe
whatever they want there you go I love
that the only guy I know who's an
executive uh of well I guess he's
president still it's owned by WME of a
Sports organization who endorsed Donald
Trump yeah I I I love and Donald Trump
obviously goes to a lot of these events
and he gets just rockus Applause and
cheers and everybody he he's talks at
the fights yeah kick him in the nuts
just kick him right in the nuts well I
don't think that's WR in the W in the
pills is what I would do I love how he's
stuck it though he he knew that he had
this guy and he goes what's your
question yeah exactly just to make sure
the guy well I was going to ask that but
I guess do you like maple syrup yes I
can feel testicular shrinkage right
now so it's a good thing that he feels
this way because there's a fighter we've
talked about him sha Strickland and and
and this is the important thing is there
could never have been a Shan Strickland
in any other sport now I know there are
some phonies out there like the Kobe
Covington and people who put on the Maga
hat where it's a gimmick Sean Strickland
is a fighter he lost a very close
decision but this is a guy through and
through who he might be a little bit
crazy which makes them a little bit
nervous but speaks his mind and he's
afforded that ability with UFC this is a
bit of a longer clip but I think you
need to see what this guy is all about
and uh see how refreshing it is Sean
Neil Davidson from the Canadian press
welcome to Canada oh congratulations
yeah the Canadian press man were you a
uh were you a uh covid bank account
stealer too are you on board with that
no are you left wi or rightwing were you
a were you a Trudeau we got one of we
got one of the commies with a press we
got to know where this man Dan were you
nonbiased
I think I'll lost the questions here oh
he thinks she'll ask we know maybe I
should just pass on this mon go back
they go back and get my bank account
information Trudeau we've got a pretty
supportive gay and lesbian community in
this city I did want to ask you about
something ago you said if I had a gay
son I would think I oh look another
another the I'm saying a swamp you guys
a swamp you become a champion you become
a star and and someone let me ask you
something are you are you are you gay
the chance with divers are you let me
know are you gay can I can I get answer
well I'm asking this is a part of are
you are you a gay man I'm an ally of the
community okay if you had a son then he
was like you know yeah son he was gay
you'd be like oh man you don't you don't
want a grandkid no problem with it oh
man well dude you're a weak man dude
you're like you're part of the problem
you elected Justin Trudeau like with you
when he sees the bank accounts like
you're just pathetic and and the fact
that pause it really quickly too we're
going to continue with this but here's
the thing he understood enough here this
isn't just hey MAA he said hold on are
you a gay man he knew the question was
being framed you can see his eyeline
shift you can see the intensity of his
stair shift where he goes oh a guy's
bringing up a tweet from two years ago
this is what we're going to do and then
he decides to all right let his let his
hands go figuratively let's keep
watching because he gets pretty Earnest
for a moment he goes okay hold on let me
laser in on a point and I don't think
that I've heard an athlete do it as
sincerely as he does here at the end of
this clip backbone and and has he shut
down your country and sees bank accounts
you ask me some stupid like that go
yourself but I did want to ask also
things you said about the trans
Community you said uh this past October
when they announced the Bud Light
sponsorship that you'd go so hard on
budlight in your next fight they'll have
to accept me or denounce me when uh when
they know what and will know what they
stand for are you this guy like this
Canadian is not that Canadian are you
still going to use your fight time to
kind of speak on that here's the thing
about Bud Light 10 years ago to be trans
was a what a mental illness and now all
of a sudden people like you have weasel
your way in the world
you are you are an infection here it
goes you are the definition of weakness
everything that is wrong with the world
is because ofing you and the best thing
is is the world's not buying it the
world's not buying youring your
pedling the world is not saying you know
what you're right chicks have dicks the
world's not saying that world's saying
no there are two genders I don't want my
kids being taught about you know who
they could in school I don't want my
kids being taught about
you know their sexual preference like
dude this guy is aing enemy it's Freedom
we still have it in America we'll teach
you about it you guys don't have freedom
of speech I'm surprised what I'm saying
it's probably to get I'm probably to get
the Canadian government to arrest me I
don't give a who you I don't give a what
you want to do in life but but don't
tell kids about it don't teach that sh
in school don't don't push your agenda
don't try to brainwash wash people don't
try to go past parents don't try to go
past all this and brainwash people
you little bit different from gimmicky
look yeah and here's the thing you'll
have some people out there sometimes say
you know what go get yourself some fans
and yeah MAA I like Trump or yeah
they'll hit some buzzwords right there
he called out Canada no freedom of
speech he's referencing the Prime
Minister seizing Trucker's bank accounts
when they were actually peacefully
protesting the government he talks about
modern gender Theory and he gets into
it's incorrect and he talks about
defending your children in public
schools sure drops a lot of fbom this is
a guy who's had a rough upbringing this
is one thing conservatives everyone out
there please understand you need people
out there like that not everything is
going to be sanitized and whitewashed
where it's a it's a college gig and
you're answering a couple of questions
and no one uses foul language that's a
sincere man who believes what he says
and there never could have been a Shan
Strickland even a few years ago yeah it
would not even be possible so I'd say
say follow him show him some love and uh
please that's a big part of what we're
dealing with this year Spot the
Difference between gimmickry and
sincerity everyone's looking for
something real let's start spotting the
people who are real my hats off to him
even though he may as ineloquent as he
may be sometimes gosh he hit he he hadit
a lot of nails right on that well he he
did it in Canada like he didn't do it
here where there are really no
consequences I mean there could be like
some political whatever fine he did it
in a place that doesn't have jum her mop
telling you you shouldn't think yeah he
did it in the Lion's Den I mean it isn't
a place known for you know being the
worst in the world on Free Speech but
certainly recently they've done some
incredibly egregious things with the the
trickers and everything else he he said
it there and he said it to those
reporters like oh you're one of those
guys that guy that Canadian's not I
guarantee you there was a Canadian
reporter next to this guy rolling his
eyes like this guy's going to ask this
question he's like that Canadian is not
that this is the shift where we would be
banned on campus for there are only two
genders Chang my mind right that would
happen all the time and banned on
YouTube he not only said there are only
two gend
he said I don't give I don't care who
you want to right screw uh just don't
effing teach your kids don't you're the
enemy this is more extreme than what we
have said because the guy is just people
are fed up and this is what I tell you
do not be don't be guarded with your
speech anymore if you know you're not a
racist then speak you don't don't be
afraid of them calling you a racist if
you know that you're not a trans phobe
whatever that means I don't know how you
get over it touch therapy with a fake
Hatchet wound touch it you'll get
it burns the point is you know who you
are let the world know who you are
that's it smash the rumble button if
that's how you feel Let your freak flag
fly and you know what you're seeing it
with everyone else to it's contagious
the cultural shift regardless of
politics is now contagious Joe Rogan
reacted to the crowd's chance about
Justin Trudeau who by the way was
immensely popular because he legalized
weed for a while and here is Joe Rogan
uh reacting to it uh during the live
stream of the
fights
D crazy I'm sorry that's the wrong I
apologize Keith and Kevin you deserve
better than that but we can't provide it
that was that was so here is take it out
with the Prime Minister not me he did it
like 19 times here's Rogan commenting on
the chance in
Canada yell
true love it yeah Canada Canada get your
together come back come back to what you
used to be do you feel it do you feel
the cultural shift guys it's happening
yeah it is ABS hey so I'm assuming he's
not he he's usually ringside doing uh he
doesn't do a lot of international events
well I I wonder why I know's probably
not jabbed right so I don't I don't
remember I don't remember if he was
against the jab I think I think he was I
don't think he is he's jabbed with
everything else just not the he's a
walking pin cushion yes and they won't
let you in in Canada no well I don't
think they strict jabbed either so well
think I'm just going to bleed
into just oh they freeze the truck is
back this is crazy oh no this is nuts
ow can't do that
what are you it's silly goofy dum
dum what there's a sound in the ocean we
don't even know what it
is that's how I picture he sounds like
that
Comm a little same little bit yeah uh
all right and this is why this is why
social media is an overdrive right
that's why did the Clean Slate campaign
because the algorithm wants to determine
what you see that video strong pre-fight
press conference you'd think it would
have more than 170,000 plays wouldn't
you Millions yeah that's it on YouTube
but guess what when people see it you
react you clip it you get it out there
you are the Army you are the Agents of
change the algorithms that exist right
now we use that term it is a brain that
isn't human that doesn't even exist that
wants to determine the direction of
culture and what Sean said is right
people aren't buying it you need to let
everyone know that you're not buying it
okay speaking of um not buying people
were not buying what governor Ronda
santis was selling now to be clear we
all here like Ronda probably the best
Governor really in the country AB
abolutely history yes well I don't know
there's probably someone down the line
who freed some
slaves that's the old
news I'm talking about today certainly
would be up there and by the way you
know Governor Abbott Texas he's a
wheelchair guy now
yeah Ron D santis officially ended his
uh presidential campaign and you
probably have already seen this this is
what they're talking about everywhere
CNN uh he endorsed though to the
surprise of many uh not everyone but a
lot he endorsed Donald Trump accordingly
I am today suspending my campaign I'm
proud to have delivered on 100% of my
promises the will stop now it's clear to
me that a majority of Republican primary
voters give Donald Trump another chance
they watch his presidency get styed by
Relentless resistance and they see
Democrats using lawfare this day to
attack him I've had disagreements with
Donald Trump such as on the Corona virus
pandemic and his elevation of Anthony
fouchy Trump is superior to the current
incumbent Joe Biden that is clear I
signed a pledge to support the
Republican nominee and I will honor that
pledge he has my endorsement because we
can't go back to the old Republican
guard of yester year a repackage formed
of warmed over corporatism that Nikki
Haley represents the days of putting
Americans last of cow toow to large
corporations of caving to woke ideology
are over and by comment below um did you
think he was going to endorse Trump or
Nick a lot of people thought he might
throw his weight behind Haley I thought
he disliked Trump enough what what did
you guys think uh I don't well that's
just because he was going against Trump
he wanted to be the next president but
he's he's not woke Nicki haly is a woke
so he's not
going how you really feel and y'all
remember when he first announced that he
was going to run for president he was
polling a lot better but when he start
indicting Trump and and Prosecuting him
pers then everything changed yeah he
made some mistakes we'll go through his
top three mistakes but then and then
Donald Trump of course now he's like I
always loved Ron yeah I'm retiring to
sanctimonia never like that name anyway
not sure where it came from not sure
where it came from frankly other people
said it that wasn't me they say he's the
sanctimonious I say don't say that he's
a nice
I appreciate though look he attacked
Nikki Haley pretty hard in of the the
debates that they had and I appreciate
that that wasn't just for his own
benefit like he truly does believe that
about her because he's saying it now
about her again in regard to helping
Donald Trump look it's between Donald
Trump and Nikki Haley now so hopefully
everyone can come together to uh ensure
that Nikki Haley no longer exists how do
how is she polling so good though it
doesn't make any sense
breasts voters you got there Women
Voters like Mone did you hear she just
said it was really hard being raised in
the Deep South as a brown woman it's
like you come on you're not you're
barely Tae I thought she was white yeah
and the black community bits you white
in the brown Community you also
white so again we have to do this out of
consistency we all like Ronda STIs and I
hope he goes back to being a great
Governor I think he'll be a formid
candidate in the future y we want to
congratulate him on a hard-fought
campaign yeah but in the spirit of
consistency Ron D santis it's time to
close Florida Governor Ron D santis is
feeling the heat today following his
glitch filled launch of his presidential
campaign he has gone back and forth as
to how he pronounces his last name
whether it's D santis or DeSantis listen
the way to pronounce my last name winner
time to
close endings and Beginnings are ending
and beginning
now there's a new sheriff in town so as
president would I use force would I
treat him as forign terrorist
organizations You're darn right I would
before we get started thank you everyone
Governor D santis I want to present to
you this participation
trophy what they're trying to say with
this is that in your boots you have
heels I got a gift for you I'd love for
you to wear okay I shop at FGL okay
and I got I don't accept gifts I can't
accept it I totally get I'm sorry I
know it's time for to
close I know that it's time for things
to
[Music]
close you know he could have let but
David know before he got that far like
you know he was waiting for the bag to
come out I I listen buddy I do not
accept gift no look let me put it to you
that way it's not a gift it's a campaign
donation right so right up give it to
your pack no one's the wiser then I'm
the guy who of course runs rentus what
and you know you answer to me what yeah
uh what's up what just he got some neck
action going what do you mean he just
yeah oh no he was attacked by an
alligator ah makes
sense there's a Disney thing was on his
dad's shoulders uh so comment below what
you think the top three things that Ron
DeSantis went did did wrun I don't even
know if it's DeSantis or DeSantis I
don't know I still don't know DeSantis
but uh number one he hired terrible
advisers this is what he did um and he
he he hired a lot of swamp creatures now
this sort of gave the illusion that he
was more establishment than he was and
we saw this with people like uh you saw
it with um Carly fiorina you see it with
a lot of people sort of
anti-establishment then they reach a
certain threshold and they go I have to
hire those people with experience so his
communications director was a Chris
Christie guy um which you saw in in his
announcement video was like wait a
minute this is not the fire breathing
like going after journalist on the spot
guy we fell in love with which is why
I'm so happy to see him endorsing Donald
Trump as opposed to Nikki Haley because
he was surrounded by a lot of
establishment uh I want to say campaign
managers and directors we're not talking
about the people who were actually
telling him what he could say but these
people end up managing your campaign and
that leads us to number two what he did
is started running his campaign a lot of
people do this like a front runner when
you're an underdog and it's very very
different you have to take it from the
champ you see him in the debates he was
not coming out as strong as he needed to
and he didn't portray himself actively
as anti-establishment as he needed to
considering that he endorsed Donald
Trump there should have been no
confusion as to if he was going to back
out if he was going to be a trump guy or
going to be a Nikki Haley guy and I
don't know when I see that someone voted
for Nikki Haley I I I guess you're
Lindsey Grahams fan I I haven't met you
I don't know
how that happens and also you know the
if you're going to talk tough talk tough
talk you know Sean strick not Hey listen
here Buckaroo you take your Buster
Browns back to the Panhandle we don't
play that kind of of of hookie here yeah
in Miami Dade what are you saying I
think you catch my drift Buster we don't
that's the problem well then maybe you
need to go back to school and repeat a
grade because you sound I'm not the s
word which
one it it's a synonym for dumb
Buckaroo the interaction he would have
that's you can go to at double hockey
sticks oh wait whoa whoa that's a
quarter Ron yes he's got his own swear
jart the house
yeah he puts his own money in the I am
so sorry I'm sorry I I didn't say it but
I spelled it DeSantis you know better
than this you know better
than I like them just to be clear I like
them I like them a lot uh and by the way
hey you guys can you know you get the
Hodge twins their new studio their new
setup Alex Jones for everything uh that
you get with mugclub we now are offering
it you can go mugas just $9 a month if
you don't want to join for 89 annually
and we have to do that because the mug
is very expensive to ship and hand paid
and hand etch but a lot of you want to
see what you get uh $9 a month you can
just push the mug club button right
there join download the rumble app and
it allows us to continue with the kind
of investigative journalism too that you
will see tomorrow speaking of mug Club
Rumble this is a big win for rumble you
guys you guys followed this on Monday uh
Dave poroy Monday is today why do I why
did I say he announced that bar stool
Sports is now forming a new partnership
with Rumble he said with the power of
barol sports we are going to help Rumble
be the top player in the video cloud and
live streaming space look it only takes
a couple of people for an exodus people
think that YouTube is ubiquitous for
online streaming and video viewing that
is Shifting and I will tell I will will
stake my reputation on the fact that
Rumble believes what they say absolutely
youve never heard me say that about
another company ever yeah and I don't I
don't take that lightly you know how I
know that how backing it up with where
it hurts financially for them they're
under a short sell target attack right
now much like what was it AMC was it AMC
that was on uh GameStop GameStop was on
AMC was a part of it as well after
GameStop the exact same kind of thing
and they are not flinching at all and
they've been banned by Foreign
government
abolutely did you guys know that entire
government like I think it was France
like we cannot allow sent a letter they
said because of the allegations Russell
BR you shouldn't be monetizing he was
like what first you're England you lost
the twice second yeah he hasn't been
convicted of anything yet and he's just
posting videos he's not posting videos
on how to sexually assault somebody
potentially listen there's a way to do
it while they're sleeping right
yeah it's like come on I think he's
going to be on the show this week
actually Russell Brand no from what I
understand
yeah I mean he's back he's back so
obviously the investigation went on and
they said to rumble the UK government
they said he you can't have uh you can't
have Russell Brand on there and they
said yes we can they're like well guess
that's the end of the
line what you said the Billy the billy
clubs would work we need Firearms yeah
they don't have guns they so yeah
there's a big win for you can download
the rumble app it's the best way to use
it uh let's go on to the oh that's a
cool graph wait hold I haven't seen
this that's nice new to me so it's like
I think we we used it once it's like
it's like the intro to drive yes yeah
it's very 80s Let's uh let's look right
now really quickly on CNN uh this Gen X
Nirvana fan I guess is talking about
Nikki Haley is ramping up attacks
against Donald Trump they love that
let's watch it is that an issue that's
being talked about or is that on the
back burner man voice you know not as
much as I might have thought um I think
that really depends on the demographic
as well uh Democrats that is obviously a
motivating factor and you will see that
across the spectrum of Republicans I
cannot say that I've heard I did not
expect those voices from those two I
didn't expect her to talk like this
thought you have like an Eddie
V he
[Laughter]
what did you say
Iowa Iowa New Hampshire I don't
know it's a style Choice okay so they
want to keep Nikki Haley alive
figuratively in the campaign okay fine
um and this is really important look
this kind of brings us back to the 2016
election there's only one person who's
really talking about protecting uh the
Border in the United States and we have
discussed this quite a bit but there are
some updates uh and this is kind of
because this affects a lot we've been
working on some hidden camera uh some
investigative journalism here behind the
scenes and almost all of these issues
end up leading back to the Border issue
right the one that you'll see tomorrow
the sex trafficking leads back to the
Border issue we have something on China
buying up giant marijuana grow farms and
they bring in slave labor effectively
through an open border so a lot of you
just think oh it's people seeking a
better life no you need to think about
the people in charge who benefit from
Mass slave labor and I do mean Mass
slave labor there are more slaves right
now on Earth than ever in recorded
history it still goes on now mostly
happens in the Middle East in Asia and
the continent of Africa but you do have
them here it's people who work off the
books who come here illegally you want
to eliminate modern slavery in the
Western World you need to have borders
and a guest book so the southern border
right now is completely open yeah you
know I don't need to couch my friend
it's completely open December so on
alltime record of
302,000 border crossings this is during
the holiday season when they should be
shopping we want to begin with the dire
situation at the southern border new
Customs and Border Protection data by CS
news show that agency is on track to
process more than
300,000 migrants an alltime monthly high
that includes record numbers of families
and children meanwhile cities states and
federal law enforcement report being
overwhelmed as the Ripple effects spread
from border communities to all across
the country by the way when lawmakers
and elected officials are overwhelmed
that's long after you mhm you the ples
have been overwhelmed you've had to deal
with the consequences now it's at their
door just to be clear there's a sequence
to that now you also need to admonish me
because I cited a number to you right
before he went to break that the record
of border crossings in a month was
269,000 no no that actually that was
correct that was the that was the that
was the old record that was smashing the
record before that so that was but I
cited that in November but that was
correct it was correct yes we just the
world record the United was 269,000 in
September that was more than ever but we
broke it by like 33,000 people in
December so you need sorry you need to
admonish me again yeah it's a false
admonishment so admonish me for the
false
admonishment wow there you go the point
is the point is my half African-American
gentleman this is really bad half yeah
it's I'm not half I'm wait all American
it's nothing African about
me somewhere down your lineage someone's
chasing a gazelle uh he black
them you can do that yes I can so last
last year
2.48 million Crossings wow now let's
compare this to the Trump High the high
just to be clear here's the low here's
the low here's the high low high 2.48
Million last year okay low Donald
Trump's High 2019 was 977 th000 wow oh w
wow someone say that's more that's
that's between a half and a third low
high yeah that's his worst year and the
media has you believing that it's all
poor families crossing over well that's
the first thing that she said including
a record number of women and children
immediately pull on the heartstring show
an image of a woman and a child it's
probably the only one they could
possibly
find exactly and I want to get into the
the macro here with you what this is
what the left tries to do they always
try and say like well we want to solve
this problem they hold out the dreamers
they hold out the kids don't you care
about these kids they don't even believe
in deporting violent criminals who are
overcrowding our prisons who have no
right to be here okay so the rate
limiting factor is not children then
they also say things like well you know
if we could work with Republicans we
have a bill that they won't sign when
then you find out that the bill gives
immunity to everybody yeah so the the
devil's in the details now the media of
course also wants you to believe that
this is nothing more than poor families
crossing over but trying to find one if
you actually look it's like trying to
find Waldo found him and it's the the
one and he's still he's still not a
family no yeah well it wasn't December
Crossing he's looking very
festive he came ready to party was there
like a was there a black Waldo did you
like cuz you know like black Santa was
there like black Waldo no it's not a
black thing to do look for
Waldo we have no patience looking for
someone goes missing you put their
face in a t-shirt yeah we have black
Jesus that's right that's you do have
black believe that IM if Jesus was black
yeah how we all
are say that Middle Eastern you say that
we could be could what it's Middle
Eastern could be Mediterranean yeah oh
yeah that's that'd be good like
Ethiopian almost I'd be more concerned
if Simon was black cuz he'd just run off
with that
cross o shut up that's heavy I don't
think you'd be able to that was that was
uh so that was
unist I feel like it's a Spider-Man meme
now we're all like it really is
yeah okay so here's the thing
immigration is the top priority the top
priority or one of the top priorities
for at least 35% of Voters and so what
we have right now is that this is the
gaslighting and that's a term that
people use but I want to use it
correctly the Democrats are trying to
blame this of course on Republicans
which I just think most people don't
believe because it was only a few months
ago where Democrats were saying you guys
are racists because you don't want to
let anyone in uh without a without a
guest card so I don't know how they
think they're going to make this work
but they're really really trying to make
it a let's go through the claims right
now the changing claims from the left to
try and cover their own ass versus the
truth here's a claim that you are going
to hear and by the way I always forget
to say this now all references available
at lwith credit.com the bibliography
please dive in as deep as you want their
claim is that Republicans are the ones
who won't fund border security the first
bill that we dropped the first bill that
we offered right after inauguration was
to fix the immigration system a
comprehensive plan
immigration system do you think they've
taken it up no but frankly we're in an
election year and the folks who want to
return Donald Trump to the White House
would prefer to talk about a broken
immigration system instead of focusing
on the solutions that are at hand oh go
spread your legs for another mayor you
Kami you fake black who woman that voice
I mean it's just amazing that she HED
her way to the top considering I mean
you wouldn't be able to dirty talk from
that lady for one second yeah harder oh
God you're fantastic I've never met
anyone like you you're you're a love
machine like oh that's a demon
no that's the claim here's the
truth that the Democrats sure they put
something in front of they want that
money to fund processing not
apprehending let alone deporting illegal
immigrants let me give you some facts
here the White House is um they've put a
request for basically it pairs Ukraine
and Israel funding with $4 billion for
the Border only 17% would go to border
patrol and most of that 177% is for
processing meaning assisting with them
coming through not stopping illegal
Crossings this is not new I've lived
through this you can go back I remember
doing videos on this probably in 2010
Barack Obama would do this all the time
he would use rhetoric I I think I don't
have the clip in front of me I think he
said no I would if there was a deal on
my desk tomorrow you know and of course
really it was like Police Academy where
he had a guy under the podium but let's
see what he had to say and I've said
time and time and time again to Congress
that send me the DREAM Act put it on my
desk and I will sign it right away
ah now both parties wrote this
legislation and a year and a half ago
Democrats passed the DREAM Act in the
house but Republicans walked away from
it it 55 votes in the Senate but
Republicans blocked it now hold on a
second before I give you is anyone
buying this does anyone actually look
even if you're a liberal do you actually
buy that it's Republicans who are not
interested in securing our borders and
the Democrats actually do that liberals
that the left are the ones who are
looking for border security comment does
anyone actually buy that just as a
general narrative and that's
what he would no and the Republicans are
walking away and uh but yeah just like
your husband
[Laughter]
Michael who there's another L blue but
it's that what he's talking about that
bill would have given citizenship to
over 2 million illegals and there was no
border security funding none Whats
that's why Republicans uh you know
walked away they got all we weed up
you're just making up stuff that's a
term in the South it's not a term in the
South you're a liar no absolutely that
that the reason is that Democrats look
at solving this problem as giving
everybody who's here amnesty that has
always been their starting point
Republicans look at this and go well
hold on I understand that there is a
problem here that we have to deal with
right we don't want to be inhumane to
anybody but can we at least maybe stop
the bleeding first maybe build the wall
maybe have some Security First and by
the way the 177% that goes to processing
processing isn't what a lot of people
think processing isn't like hey the
line's long let's put some more people
up and some more cash registers and get
these people through legally no
processing is oh you want to claim
Asylum fantastic let me fill out your
paperwork that you're never going to
show up for court and kind of confirm
and you may go off into the country by
the way here's a gift card like they
literally do that kind of stuff that's
the processing that they're talking
about that's why they never want this
problem solved they just want more
people and they want to turn them into
voters yes yes every time they want to
turn them in the vo but imagine how many
sex slaves do you think have been
processed how many people being
trafficked children being trafficed yeah
how many children who are out there
working in the grow fields that are
being purchased by China right now do
you think have been processed either
either they've not been processed at all
or it's just as easy to go through
they're not actually they have no way to
vet these people and send them back look
if you live this is foolish okay this is
foolish to start with so however you
feel about immigration if you're a
Libertarian who thinks that you know
what let's just let the market deter
okay fine before we get to that it is
foolish to not actually have a system of
checks and balances and vetting in place
to know who's coming into our country
you live in foolish foolishness long
enough you become evil it's a descent
into evil it's foolishness and it
becomes evil because you end up enabling
the most evil Among Us drug cartels sex
traffickers people who are purchasing up
land to use slave labor now let's
contrast this with the Republican House
Bill and again I'm not fans of
Republicans have not been strong enough
on the immigration issue that's why
Donald Trump's campaign was a huge bang
when he remember they're not sending
their brightest and people said that's
the racist thing he said he didn't say
all of Mexico but still the Republican
bill hr2 and the referen is available L
of.com it would require employers to
verify that all employees are legal
there you go hey hey you know what
that's putting some pressure on the
employers wouldn't wouldn't we all be
happy with that it'll make face jail
time if they don't do it yep by the way
you may want to talk with your lawn crew
it'll make it much
harder to claim Asylum it'll fund the
construction of more border wall and it
will not include amnesty here's
something else too with the country
before I get into the macro as to how
you cease to have a country if you don't
have borders this fight over uh the
Border it's it's also becoming like a
major conflict between Federal uh law
enforcement and federal legislators and
local and it really shouldn't be just to
be clear this is one of the few
legitimate roles of the federal
government to ensure that you are safe
from external threats I mean I'm a very
limited government guy a federalist and
I know the name sort of obviously is
counterintuitive but that is one of the
few roles of federal government you
can't expect Idaho to solve the Border
issue right and it's not Texas cuz if
Texas solves it guess what California
chooses not to you're right back where
you started this is a federal issue we
have Federal borders so let me give you
an example here in Eagle Pass uh Texas
authorities they started claiming uh
jurisdiction over Shelby Park which was
formerly uh a CBP processing center news
of the deaths of three migrants a woman
and two children who drowned in the
river last week with Congressional
Democrats blaming Texas and Texas
blaming the Biden Administration a new
Supreme Court filing shows Federal
officials were informed by Mexico of the
deaths and when a border patrol official
went to Shelby Park they spoke through
the closed gate and Texas National
Guardsmen refused to let border patrol
enter because they had been ordered not
to allow border patrol access to the
park good yep good by the way did you
did you catch that there were I don't
know if you followed this in the news at
all they were saying they didn't let
them have access to it almost like they
were trying to save the migrants from
drowning and like the Texas National
Guard just B like haha let them drown no
they were already dead the Mexican
Government had just kind of told us
about it right and they were trying to
get access to to the park there and I'm
like good you know what you relocate
Washington DC to El Paso and I'm pretty
sure this problem gets solved quickly
yeah she Turtle yeah that's true walking
through the desert yes since it's so far
away they don't get to see it so we just
bust people to you and here's the crazy
thing the only Democrat in Washington
now I've been very hard on him and I
will continue to be because it's funny
but yes of course credit where it's due
the only Democrat in Washington that
seems to understand and is willing to
acknowledge that there's a problem with
border security and of course the left
is turning on them is Mr stroy moker
himself Mr John fed Mr whater I honestly
don't understand why it's controversial
to say we we need a secure border uh
I've been very clear in fact that was
weaponized against me as Republicans in
my race that I'm very much uh strong
supporter of immigration and you know my
my wife's family that's the Oregon story
about that uh and I think things can be
true at the same time you can be very
supportive of immigration but we also
need to have a secure border to be fair
between between commercial breaks he was
playing Oregon Trail on his true 1994
yeah he was like lost again damn it
denter Dent he's starting to sound
better though he is starting to sound
better and as he starts to sound better
he becomes more right leaning that's
what's crazy yeah by the way he's
wearing I guess you guys all drop at the
same local yeah you make it look much
better though yeah a lot better that man
doesn't have man breasts he has low man
breasts yeah he's got slow hanging fruit
yeah
like he needs a lift he doesn't need a
he doesn't need a Bo he needs a lift
like a pregnant lady lift J
yeah makes sense you're so
sexist I mean I'm just saying those
stretch marks probably like a starburst
pattern so oh for him for him for him
for him for Mr fedman for Mr
fedman by the way it's not going very
well we here of course always have some
exclusives uh we have two today uh we
have an exclusive uh live feed as we
always do we spare no expense uh at the
border it's not going
[Music]
well this be
my yeah you you know it's easy to talk
about it until you see how it affects
real folks yeah was that a fire
tornado no listen it is a lawless Place
Mexico yeah they have fire tornadoes and
we do have an exclusive uh here too this
is a from mug Club undercover we got a
tip from an Insider at the Navy um
showing us that the Biden Administration
is redirecting troops to the border to
assist again with migrant process
processing so using National forces to
assist with basically creating a porous
National border the requests uh that
we've been tip off tipped off with
include the following to Personnel
detection monitoring data entry
warehousing Transportation assistance
meaning yeah get them where they want to
go get them to a waffle house at 3:00
a.m. let world star take care of the
rest world
star well look if they're going to be
here we have to profit off of them uh a
spe Airlines terminal either
now here's a statement too from our
source he said I I got this email from
my command it's amazing they are willing
to send us service members to The Border
instead of just enforcing our laws
making us all complicit in the
trafficking of persons and the obvious
threat of letting in terrorists into the
country it's sad what has happened and
that the US government doesn't care
about our own country anymore and if you
are out there right now and you are
working in these institutions you see
corruption we will protect you with our
lives we will go to jail to protect our
sources tomorrow we have a very big
story dropping that uh is about as risky
as you can you can uh it's as big of a
risk as you can take and we're willing
to take it so send your tips to lwc tips
protonmail.com lwc tips protonmail.com
it's encrypted we will protect your
anonymity um and we appreciate all the
tips that we get here's the thing
borders the go macro here you guys WR
now this is one thing when I we do the
black and white on the gray issues and
talk with people I've never met a single
black person even de black Democrat
voters who don't think that we need to
have strong borders it seems like that's
pretty common in the black community
right yeah exactly it's just that they
think the Republicans are racist right
exactly so that's why it keeps them from
voting and you know I think too black
people just don't care well a lot of
them do when I spoke there there were
the two there was a lady getting her
hair done she said you know what do you
think she called me back after the
conversation was over she said what do
you think about people who come here you
know they don't learn the language like
they don't learn English I said okay
well it's inter that you asked me that
because as a white person if I answered
it typically I'd be accused of being
racist I think that we actually need a
national language and it should be
English and I think that we need to have
secure borders and know who's coming in
and they all they all agreed they
brought it up they're so much more
conservative than they often realize but
they the biggest Hypocrites they run to
the poll with a 90
[Music]
90%
who are here legally believe that we
need to have laws borders historically
let me be clear here they've always been
crucial they are essential to
sovereignty even the UN says this and
now they really really hate borders if
you look at other nations outside of the
United States Mexico is Israel but
Mexico has unbelievably strict
immigration policy right Mexican
citizens they must be hired over
foreigners the proof of status for
non-citizens must be given at any time
and by the way they even it even extends
to owning waterfront property yeah well
to be clear the only thing you have to
say if you're coming across the southern
border is I'm on my way to the United
States and they'll let you go exactly
that's fine you're like that's okay yeah
you can go there you can be there
problem don't don't stop here though
yeah well Mexico doesn't want to be
filled with a bunch of el salvadorians
no or Guatemalans like we don't want
they those those people are
animals they're so racist to other
countries not even kidding it's
hilarious they all look
alike like well hold on tell me which is
Honduran I can't tell I don't think so
it's back for you like Chinese and
Japanese they all look Alik to me I
don't care they all look Muslim what
Chinese and Japanese what the hell are
you talking about no I'm talking about
uh Mexicans like when went to London did
some C show it was we was doing a show
in London right and ke's like man I
didn't know so many Mexicans in London
that's like I think they're
Muslim are they laughing at your jokes
tell they're not going to die one of
them's ticking
[Laughter]
now here's the thing too is um look
don't feel guilty don't be don't be brow
beating just we just talked about Sean
Strickland we talked about there's a
cultural shift Donald Trump was a bll on
a china shop no one cares anymore if you
say yep we need a border Federman saying
it now you have you have uh Camala
Harris saying it and trying to blame
Republicans at one point in time if you
said hey we need to create a wall people
said you go back to the change build a
wall change my mind people would say
racist racist racist racist the left
isn't even trying to use that accusation
anymore why because of how bad their
policies
have how bad of a situation they found
themselves because of their own you have
four states in this country okay you
have the biggest states are uh
California Texas Florida New York I
don't know the order two are red two are
blue two two blue States everyone is
leaving two red States they don't have
enough room to keep building Texas and
Florida there you go
it's a very very similar population
distribution same thing as far as
demographics although Florida's a little
bit older but you have a mix mix of
races gender hey it doesn't work and
they know this on a national level so
now they're kind of drifting away from
racist to well you don't actually want
to solve the problem don't let them do
it stop muzzling yourself Let your freak
flag fly Donald Trump if today he were
to say they're not they imagine
the argument back then it was hey this
is cruel we need to give amnesty we need
to we need to allow dreamers there are
kids who are born here and through no
fault of their own we can't Deport their
parents right that's what they were
saying and so they said Donald Trump was
racist during that Dynamic when he said
they're not sitting their brightest if
you don't have a border you're not going
to have a country anymore folks imagine
today how they would call him racist
when they're trying to say that they're
securing the Border they can't they'd be
tilting at windmills that's the shift
and here's another thing by the way
building a wall just pragmatically would
be way cheaper than paying for illegal
immigrants the way that we do so the
estimated cost this comes from NPR by
the way the gayest of news
sources and their estimate is a wall $
11 billion MH 11 billion dollar that's
an estimate you can find it as high as
20 something billion you know how much
the the average taxpayer has to pay or
collectively for illegal immigrants in
this country illegal immigration it
costs taxpayers $150 billion a year $150
billion a year so you have the pragmatic
argument of course it's far more
expensive to support this system than it
is to Simply create a wall or have some
basic border security by the way the
wall is just kind of a catchall term
meaning of course we need to actually
have systems in place that prevent
people from coming here illegally Cy
cyber security all of that right yeah 11
billion 150 billion then there's the
moral argument well how do you cut down
on sex trafficking how do you cut down
on slave labor it's the same answer good
news is it's more
affordable and speaking of hiring
employees yeah on the books do we still
have Charles Xavier's no brother Chet
yeah I know we put on retainer did that
end going into the new year no he's
still here he's still working here yeah
you want me to check on him please
please okay hold on
[Music]
go hey Kim where's Chad his chair is
empty he's uh using cerebro
cerebro
what the hell are you
doing I'm using cerebro do you mind
that's a massage chair it does other
things you're
get
[Music]
out have a nice massage
sorry that's why your checks have become
a little bit thinner ke and Kevin we to
pay for we didn't get what we thought we
were getting yeah I knew that it was too
good to be true looks like white
privilege
again very white privileg yeah and this
is something else too people will
constantly point to I just don't want
you to be tripped up with this argument
the Statue of Liberty give us you're
tired you're poor you're hungry okay
here's the thing compare if you look at
people who came to this the Irish the
Jews Italians Germans depending
depending on the era they came to a
country um with no promise of anything
in return a lot of them it was all right
go go and try your hand at taming the
unit give it a world it's it's it's the
new world that's very different when
people are fleeing persecution or
they're fleeing famine or they're
fleeing
tyranny versus people who are coming to
a country to benefit from a welfare
state to the tune of $150 billion from
taxpayers it's not the same thing it is
a fundamental difference in the in the
reason as to why people are are
migrating here if people were migrating
here right now you could have you know
what you technically could have open
borders if you said okay you come to
this country you get
zero welfare benefit you get zero social
safety net benefits no social security
nothing you don't get to go into a
hospital and leave they will cuff you
unless you pay cash yeah if you said
that and you ensured that people were
not gaming the system treating them like
the immigrants of the early 19th century
or pick your
decade guess what you wouldn't have the
problem people are coming here for free
stuff it's very very different so to act
as though contextually you don't
understand the difference is
disingenuous and if you find yourself
tripped up with that argument do not
allow it to take place anymore something
else a lot of you know you've heard of
Oregon Trail and all this like T in the
west yeah give an idea how crazy it was
even they offered people you know coming
over from Europe a lot of them who
didn't speak English then you come to
the United States at this point they
were moving West they said you go yes
yes you go west you get free land and
they say whatever like I don't know how
they speak German or polish whatever
that's pretty
ACC like da da da and they like Okay
cool so you get free land when you go
and so that a lot of them didn't know
how to swim and they got on boats they
came over here they started homesteading
you know like all you fake tradwives
want to say that you do and here's the
the government didn't even tell them
about the the Lakota and the Comanche oh
they come and they set up and they're
just sitting like all right we got
another the
so that was a screw job it was so
different migration today not not only
did they not really give them a bunch of
they didn't tell them about the pitfalls
yeah and they just thought hey rather
than throw soldiers at it let's just
take a bunch of you know polish German
whatever and uh give them some land and
let them fight it
out Shi that'll work what what we can do
I just give them land yeah I want about
the arrows um my parents when they came
they never took not my parents my wife's
parents they never took any Ware or
anything they said because they didn't
want to be AIT on the system and then
when we go to grocery stores and you see
all these immigrants and grocery stores
all of them had EBT cars which is Ware
it's like man that's just it's
California yeah like everybody every
time you go into the grocer storees like
majority population is Latino and they
all have that same bank car with the
mountains on
it I
like someone find the car that they're
talking about the research the bank
carard with the mountains on itare car
and all of them got nice cars and buying
lobster and steak there was a Christmas
where we had an old television that we
got from a sports bar from my cousin in
Montreal and it was I mean this was
Furniture this thing was huge like
Reagan was President yeah when this TV
existed and uh for Christmas finally I
got my parents a new TV back then it was
plasma which was you know that was a new
and it was like four oh my God 45 in
that was crazy it was huge I could pick
it up and hold it think of Peter
Dinklage his his line for being rich was
each I have three homes each with a
50-inch plasma screen like nowadays you
go to Costco that's where the poor
people shop they like 50 in 70 at least
yeah for $200 in WM I know I know
that's how good things get
technologically but these people so we
put it for free on Craigslist this old
TV when I got my parents a new one and
the people who came to pick it up were
Latino mhm and they were laughing their
asses off at my parents they having this
old cheap TV at this point they had
smartphones and they were like taking
pictures like ah look how they
look how poor white people are my
parents like could you just take we're
giving it to you for free you don't need
to humiliate us White Privilege
man Canadian too what's that haircut $5
over here of a fade so they just
came to make fun of your parents they
came to make fun of my parents and They
carried it out like we're probably going
to put in the trash really we just
wanted it for a j we didn't think it was
real they were mocking my not like they
weren't mean about it they were pretty
mean about it but they couldn't believe
and that's just because my parents were
saving to get into a house and hey you
know what ends up happening doesn't
matter we had Fanny May Freddy Mack we
had Frank Dodd where at that point hey
people who couldn't get in a house got a
house with no money down in the name of
it's all in the name of diversity just
to be clear it's all in the name of
equity rather than equality and then you
had people like my parents who ran into
a situation where they could put 20%
down and then at that point no no no
sorry because we got screwed in the
market crashed and so these other people
were living in houses driving cars they
couldn't afford buying electronics that
they had no business buying and laughing
at people like my parents my family or
myself who saved money wisely you live
in foolishness long enough you descend
into evil and that is what is happening
with the immigration situation in this
country it is evil to not seal these
borders I believe that it is a moral
impair if you do not believe in sealing
the Border building a wall and making
sure that we know who is coming into
this country I believe that you are
acting as a tool knowingly or
unknowingly of evil because there are
sex slaves and there are slave slaves we
can't stop it we can't stop it unless we
start taking at least these steps let's
just be clear about it you don't get to
take the moral High Ground when you
allow people to be enslaved which is
still happening today absolutely Anyway
by the way we do have the card oh let me
see the card on a lighter note that's
the card
there it is the Golden State Advantage
ah yes it looks like a fake car right
yeah it does look like a fake car no
it's like you see this place you're
never going to see that place in real
life uh is that like Machu picu yeah no
no it's not oh I have a brother he's a
Lon King over there he killed a guy I
remember when we was on warfare as kids
we used to go up to the grocer store and
when Daddy that fake Monopoly money okay
let's get out of here going to see that
money and say oh the these Negroes are
on warfare you actually brought in
Monopoly money well that's what it look
like oh what in Virginia they give you
this like I look like fake money you
going there and you be all embarrassed
like
ear oh thank you I feel like a slave
walking out there thank you master
thanks for giv me these it so
embarrassing shut up it should be
embarrassing yeah you should it should
be embarrassing a little bit a little
bit I mean damn it was your fault you
were a kid but you know it's the hey
look we we live in a country that helps
someone
uh when they're down in their luck all
right M but people who are chronically
on that and that's the problem they're
abusers of the system it's a safety net
not a hammock asked again I asked uh
when we did the black and white and the
gray issues you can go watch it uh on
Rumble I said hey how about this how
about for welfare they said well you
know there are a lot of white people
abuse welfare too more white people than
black people because of the population
sure the percentage of the population
but I said hey how about this before we
get into black versus how about we find
some common ground what about if someone
goes to pick up government benefits I
said how about uh drug testing and they
said absolutely I said and how about if
you've been on welfare and you're
able-bodied for more than a few months
there's a work requirement meaning you
work for the government as opposed to
paying government employees you work you
get your welfare whether it's janitor
whether it's paperwork whether it's
being a secretary unskilled while you
get trained for the job market they said
yeah that sounds great every single
black person agreed but that never makes
it to the ballot from
Democrats think about black people keep
voting for the Democrats right
I'm tired of these and then you know
they buy votes with those uh those
mountainous cards the Golden State
Advantage there is no Golden State
Advantage anymore what are you talking
about citizen citizen
dwindling about the what is what is the
opposite of population growth what's the
term I'm looking for depopulation what
is it I mean shrinkage shrinkage happens
you're buying it with the shrinkage card
all right speaking of shrinkage we have
one more story exclusively because we
can't do it uh at all on YouTube uh it's
about a Jewish sperm owner being denied
oh because anti-Semitism poor guy it
even goes It goes down to the molecular
level
does before we leave thank you guys we
are back tomorrow we will be relying on
you for the push because uh look you'll
see what we're talking about this has
been a big one we've been working behind
the scenes tirelessly thank you to The
Mug Club undercover team so you can join
for 89 annually or now go mugas you
don't get the mug but you get to join
the club $9 a month just click that
button right there on Rumble and uh you
get to join I still don't like the idea
of mugas because this is the token of
and you know you know but I get it a lot
of people want to get into some people
want to try it's a better deal if you
buy the mug thank you well I I'm not why
am I leaving we're not leaving okay
thank you Rumble yeah I took kick
YouTube everything now goes to mug Club
have we had to hit the dump button today
I'm sure they have right maybe I assume
at least a couple times I've been a good
boy
today mostly you call women man
it's not very good well look at the
person I called when when women are
look and let's honest a lot of
women you can piss off a lot of women
[Applause]
[Music]
are